hello everyone and welcome i hope you're
enjoying ambercomp so far
and thank you for joining me today we're
going to be talking about how you can
build
a pinterest-like masonry layout
using technologies such as modifiers and
css grid
but first a quick introduction my name
is jordan hawker
i'm the staff front end engineer at
linkedin
and tech lead for developer experience
within my organization
this is my dog cooper he's an australian
cattle dog he's five years old and i
love him
dearly and he's gonna be helping us out
with our talk today so
keep an eye out he might be playing a
little peekaboo today
now i work for the linkedin talent
solutions ui
infrastructure team and we enable our
teams to
ship applications faster with enterprise
grade quality
by providing them with the tools they
need to work more efficiently and
productively
we support three amber applications and
nearly 60
internal add-ons and we're focused on
a number of areas including application
platform
developer experience testing
infrastructure
and operational excellence
now let's talk a little bit about
masonry layouts which you may know
as the pinterest layout now a masonry
layout is
similar to a strict grid layout where
one access
does have that very strict grid
set up but the other axis the masonry
access
eliminates any space between items
so instead of sticking to that strict
grid
usually this is vertical space so that
you have that nice layout where
no matter how tall each item is there's
the next item
below it is going to come up right
underneath it without any
major gaps now why did i care about
solving this particular problem
well last year i was working on a
side project where i wanted to build a
sort of vintage newspaper layout
so i wanted a multi-column layout where
these articles
would finish at any unknown length
and then the next article would be begin
below it
right where the article finished so in
any given column
uh as articles had different lengths i
wouldn't necessarily know
uh where that article would end and
where the next one would begin
so i started exploring ways to build
this sort of
masonry layout to eliminate the gaps
between articles and have this
nice newspaper look to it
so let's think about how we might
implement a masonry layout many of you
may know about the masonry javascript
library
found on github at disandro slash
masonry
it was first released in 2010 and it's
one of the most popular javascript
solutions
for masonry layouts today in fact it has
over 400
000 downloads a month on npm
and part of its popularity came from a
strong integration with
jquery over the last 10 years however
the library itself is 2
500 lines of code unminified whereas the
solution i'm going to show you today
takes less than 150 lines of code to
implement in ember
additionally the js library
was last released in 2018
so it hasn't received any modern updates
to its implementation
now let's look at a website called
which uses the masonry.js library to
implement a grid layout
now as you can see from this recording
as you resize the page
the content in the grid does get shifted
around as the number of columns
change and the library recalculates
where
things need to be positioned however
you can also see that this recalculation
takes some time
and so content gets squished together or
you get a lot of blank space between the
items
until the library catches up and shifts
the content
into its new locations so
how can we build something a little bit
more lightweight
now you may have seen a lot of demos on
the internet
of trying to accomplish a masonry layout
using
only css and html and
a lot of these demos look great and they
get you really close to
the masonry solution that we're looking
for however
there's a number of assumptions that get
built into these approaches
often a fixed number of columns or
the utilization of media queries to
adjust the number of columns based on
specific known breakpoints in the
container size additionally
you can use flexbox to implement this
sort of solution
and the way you would do that is to set
the flex
direction to be vertical along the
columns rather than along the rows
the problem here is that that makes the
ordering of items difficult because the
items themselves
would actually flow down the column
instead of flowing horizontally the way
you would expect them to
so your content may not be in the order
that you would expect with this sort of
solution
so what is it that we're actually trying
to accomplish with
a perfect masonry layout well first of
all we want to be able to account for a
dynamic number of
columns so no matter what size
the container of our grid is we want to
be able to fill that space with the
correct number of columns based on the
width of
our content in each column we also want
to make sure that we're eliminating any
unused space between
items along the masonry axis and we want
this
solution to be fully responsive with a
performant
and efficient reflow of content as the
size of the container is changed
so let's look at pinterest itself
now i'm sure many of you are familiar
with this product
and it's probably the most popular
and well-known instance of a masonry
layout on the internet today
now if you look at this recording you do
see that the content is getting
shifted around and the relative order
is more or less staying the same as it
shifts things from more columns to less
columns and moves them down
however you can also tell that
you get into situations where there's
some horizontal
scrolling involved as you make the page
smaller
and as you make the page larger there's
a lot of
white space around it until they
recalculate where everything needs to go
and then re-render the page
so let's look under the hood and
understand a little bit more
how they're accomplishing this you know
pinterest does their grid layout via
explicit
css transforms so they look at the
height and width of
each item in their grid and then they
look at the
overall height and width of the
container for the entire grid
and they use javascript to calculate the
exact
position that each item in the grid
needs to be and you can see here
that they've set explicit uh transforms
to translate each item
by a number of pixels along the x and y
axis so that everything gets laid out
nicely on the grid
now where this comes up short is that
they have noticeable delays in the way
that the content gets reflowed
because they have to recalculate the
position of every element in the grid
every time
the page resizes in order to update
those transforms
now this is a computationally heavy
approach because javascript
is slow compared to native html and css
features
however in the case of pinterest as a
product
it's possible that resize performance is
not a priority for them
if this isn't something that their users
do often
resizing the homepage they may not have
had a reason to prioritize that
performance in their solution
however if we're thinking about a more
generic
approach to a masonry layout that could
be used across any sort of product
situations
we should care about the performance of
the reflow
because we can't predict whether the
users of somebody trying to implement
this solution
are going to be the kind of users that
are going to resize the page
if it's a product that's going to be
resized often that sort of thing
so css grid comes onto the scene and
really helps us
get very close to solving this problem
first of all
it provides us with fully responsive
content
reflow that is highly configurable so
css grid as a browser feature
allows us to set the width of columns it
allows us to set the height of rows it
allows us to set
the gap between the columns and rows and
you can even
set individual pieces of content to span
multiple columns or multiple rows
which is going to be very important to
our solution today because it's a native
browser feature it has great performance
and there's no expensive calculations
that need to happen in javascript
however
css grid doesn't yet support masonry
it expects consistent content sizes that
align to the set
heights of each row and the width
of each column so we're not quite
there with being able to just do masonry
with css grid
however there is a property
of css grid called masonry that is being
worked on
it's part of the css grid 3
specification which is currently an
editor's draft
however you can see from this grid here
that the feature is still experimental
and it's not fully
implemented in any of the major browsers
so you wouldn't want to use it in
production
but can we still try to build
some sort of performant masonry layout
today the answer
is what i've been working on so i have a
project that i've been working on since
last year called
amber photo gallery and you can
actually check out this demo live today
at ember dash
photo dash gallery dot jayhawk dot co
and as you can see from this recording
what i've been able to build here will
actually efficiently reflow the content
in the grid
as you resize the page it adjusts the
number of columns
and it is able to shift the content
around without any noticeable
delays uh in terms of deciding where
everything needs to be positioned so
let's dive in a little bit to understand
how
i thought about approaching this problem
and what some of this implementation
looks like
so the first thing i wanted to do was
design a masonry grid component
that provided a generic api for
exposing this feature to any sort of
consumers
and i did that utilizing css grid and
ember modifiers so here's what the
architecture
of my ember photo gallery demo looks
like
at the top level we have a component
called
masonry grid and that component has
a modifier called masonry columns
that it wraps around the user content
that's getting passed in
now it then yields out a component
called masonry item
which has a its own modifier masonry
rose that wraps around the
individual pieces of content passed in
by the consumer
and that's where my specific demo comes
into play
because i've built a component called
unsplash photo which just lays out
the content for each photo in my grid
and it hooks up to
an api service and then it has its own
modifier internally
called on load that handles the
asynchronous nature
of loading images in the browser so that
we're able to
calculate the correct layout at the
right time once the images have fully
loaded
so let's look at what the external api
of our masonry grid component looks like
now first of all we have arguments that
allow us to essentially
configure the css grid and then we also
yield out this grid.item
which is the masonry item component that
the consumer can then use to wrap
any sort of arbitrary content that's
going into the grid
so masonry grid allows you to configure
the number of columns
the width between the width of the
columns the
space between the columns also known as
the column gap
and the row gap as well so the distance
between each row in our grid
it also yields out the masonry item
component which the
consumer will use to wrap its content
and the main goal that i wanted to have
here was
giving the consumer the full flexibility
of configuring this masonry grid
so i wanted to expose a number of the
features of css grid to
be dynamically set by the consumer and i
wanted to
make sure that i yielded this out in a
block
content api that gave the
consumer the ability to define how their
content would look
in a way that felt ergonomic and
followed best practices for ember
so internally within our masonry grid
template
we have the masonry columns modifier
which gets past a number of our
arguments it gets past the
number of columns or the string auto if
we want it to auto adjust
as the container resizes it gets past
the width of the column
and it get gets past the gap between
columns
and then we yield out a hash that
contains our masonry item component
and then we pass the row gap argument
to the masonry item component right away
so before we dive more into the
implementation i want to take a step
back
and just briefly talk about the concept
of modifiers
so for this demo i'm using ember
modifier which is an
add-on that provides an ergonomic api
for
dom interactions in ember apps modifiers
can be applied directly to elements
in the template and you can use them to
mutate dom nodes or generate
state from the dom
so our very first modifier here is
masonry
columns and masonry columns is going to
dynamically adjust the number of columns
in our grid it's also going to account
for the width of columns and the size of
the gap between columns when it
calculates
how many columns are available and it's
going to update the number of columns
automatically
using resize observer which is a more
accurate approach than static media
queries which have
preset breakpoints in the size of your
app
let's look a little bit closer at the
implementation of our modifier
now as you can see this is a class based
modifier
it has a number of getters that set the
grid width and the number of columns
and you can see i've just quickly
circled the
calculation that takes place to
determine the number of columns
all we're doing here is looking at the
width of the container itself
and we're dividing it by the width of
the column plus the gap between columns
to figure out how much of that how many
times
that space can be repeated within the
container before we
exceed the size of the container itself
then
in the constructor you can see that
we're setting up
a resize observer which is going to
uh go ahead and run the calculations
that we need
when the container gets resized
uh one thing i do want to note here is
that
if you want a performant resize observer
you can actually create one centralized
within your application and reuse it for
all resize behavior that you need
because any number of elements can be
observed by a single resize
observer however for the purposes of
simplicity within this demo i've just
gone ahead and made a new resize
observer
within the modifier itself and then at
the bottom here
in our organize grid columns method
which gets called by the resize observer
you can see that we're setting two
styles on the element
the first one is the most important
because that's our grid
template columns style which tells us
how many columns that we have and what
the width of each column is
and then also our grid column gap which
configures
the gap between columns so these are
properties of css grid
that we're setting within the modifier
which allows us to
interact with the dom
let's look at our masonry item component
which is really just a simple wrapper
around the user's content it applies a
modifier to that wrapper
and it also handles some async behavior
which we'll come back to
so the template again is very simple
it applies this masonry rose modifier on
our wrapper div
we pass the row gap in and then we pass
it
a promise which handles the async
behavior and then we're going to yield
out an action to the consumer that also
will get used for the async behavior
that we'll cover later
let's look a little bit closer at
masonry rows because this is really
where the magic
of our masonry implementation takes
place
it's going to do a number of things
first it's going to calculate the number
of rows that each content element spans
accounting for the gap between the
elements as well
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to set
the row size to 1 pixel so that we get a
pixel perfect grid layout
let me show you what i mean by that in
our css
we set grid auto rows to one pixel and
what this does
is it tells css grid that the height of
each row is exactly one pixel
so every single row in the grid is one
pixel tall
and that may seem counter-intuitive but
that's what allows us to
make this masonry layout work because
as you can see in the modifier
implementation itself
what we're going to do is calculate the
height of the element
in pixels add the row gap to it
and then set the number of rows equal to
the height
plus gap in pixels so for example
if you had a piece of content that was
200 pixels tall
and your row gap was set to say 5 pixels
then we would set the grid row end
style to span 205 rows
and since we have set a row to be one
pixel tall
then we know that we can span
205 rows
so let's add some data to our masonry
grid
on the consumer side i've used the
unsplash api
which allows me to retrieve up to 30
images at once
and for this demo i went ahead and
queried on the keyword ember because why
not
i'm also going to load the images
asynchronously
so even though the api itself is of
course asynchronous
we're also going to have to account for
the fact that once we
set the url on the image elements there
is
asynchronous loading of the image itself
in the browser
so there's not a lot you need to care
about in this data service this is
pretty much just interfacing with the
unsplash api i built a method that
retrieves random photos
and then uh returns the response from
the api
to our content uh that we're
having set up here so the
masonry item template i want to come
back to this again
we touched on it briefly but there's two
things that i want to note here one
is that the masonry rose modifier
is being passed this dot on load which
is a promise we
are going to define in the masonry item
component we have
also passed an action
and yielded it out to the consumer and
this action allows us to
as a consumer to pass a promise back to
our
wrapper component now if you look closer
at the
component class we have
this dot on load being set in the
constructor and this is just
a standard promise where we're capturing
the resolve uh part of the promise
and when we get the
promise from the consumer via the action
we're going to chain the resolution of
that promise
to the resolution of our internal
promise and what this does
is when the consumer tells us that their
async behavior is concluded
and resolves their promise then we're
going to resolve our promise which we
passed
to the masonry rose modifier and the
masonry rose modifier
is going to wait for that promise to
calculate the height of the content
so that you ensure that the calculation
happens at the right time
and doesn't happen too early if you were
to
not handle the async behavior there then
there's a possibility
that your grid would end up squished
vertically because you wouldn't have the
correct calculations of the height
if there was any sort of asynchronous
delay in the loading of the content
that would change the height of the
actual elements
so let's look a little closer at
unsplash photo which is our content
component
this is just a very simple container for
the photo and its metadata
but it also handles the async image
loading that we were just talking about
so on the left here we have our class
which just
handles the action uh that was passed in
and this action gets passed to an
on load modifier which as you can see
is being used on the image element
itself
so the onload modifier is what handles
our load events for images
and as you can see in here all it does
is create a promise that then gets
passed back
out to the unsplash photo component
and that promise resolves when
the load event on the element gets fired
so we're going to add an event listener
onto our image element and
we're waiting for the load event which
tells us that the image is fully loaded
in the browser
when that happens we're resolving this
promise which then
allows the entire promise chain to
resolve and allows us to correctly
calculate
the height of our content and that's it
we've done everything we needed to build
masonry grid
and to consume it for the demo so
a quick review of the way our
architecture is laid out
we have the masonry grid component which
exposes
the main api for configuring the grid
itself
we have masonry columns as a modifier
which configures the
columns of our css grid and this gets
wrapped around the entire content
and then we have our masonry item
component which gets yielded out to the
consumer
and it applies a masonry rose modifier
around each item in the grid
and the masonry rose modifier calculates
the height of the content in order to
make that masonry
layout work now we have the unsplash
photo component
which is the consumer side content
and it hooks up to a data service for
api and then we have
the onload modifier which
just handles the async loading of the
image in the browser
and kicks off the resolution of that
promise chain
which goes up to the masonry item
component and then back
down to the masonry rows modifier and
lets the masonry rose modifier know
that it can now safely calculate the
height of the content
in order to set up that layout
so let's take another look at the final
product here
which again you can check out for
yourself at
emberphotogallery.jayhawk.com
i'm not going to show the resizing
behavior here but what i want to
really show you is that as you refresh
the page and load in
different image content the grid is
quickly laying out in whatever
order it needs to in order to fill this
full masonry layout quickly
so no matter how tall each of the
individual images are
this is able to performantly lay out the
content
because we're mostly
leveraging the native css grid feature
in order to keep it performant the only
calculations we do on the javascript
side are a one-time calculation
of the height of the content when the
content first loads
and we set that as the css property
telling us how many rows
are spanned by each individual piece of
content
everything else is handled by css grid
itself which keeps the solution
performant and allows us to ensure that
all of the content reflow
is very efficient no matter how often
we're resizing the content
or how often we're changing the content
in the grid itself
let's talk a little bit about what your
takeaways should be from today
now there's a number of technologies
that we've used that you
can take back to your product
development at home and at work
and utilize in your everyday
development process first of all css
grid is a great feature
for modern grid layouts in the browser
it allows you to configure any number of
aspects of the grid
including the size of the columns and
rows
the gaps between each column or each row
as well as whether any individual
element spans one or more columns or one
or more rows
which as you saw was important for
solving the masonry layout today
now css grid 3 is coming soon which is
great
because once that lands it's going to
include a specification for native
masonry property on css grid
and that will actually eliminate a lot
of the work that we had to do today to
make our masonry layout work because
now masonry layout will work natively in
the browser
but until that lands and becomes a
feature that is available
in all the major browsers we can still
implement that today
using modifiers now modifiers are great
because you can attach them to any
element in a template
and easily make dom modifications or
generate stay from the dom
one of the things i love about modifiers
is that they give you
a nice barrier between the two-way
nature
of browser event bindings and the
one-way nature of ember's
state flow so that's an important
concept
to use modifiers to make sure that the
logic of your ember application
stays very clear and that the state flow
is very easy to understand
while still enabling you to interface
with native browser features
now if you'd like to check out the code
from
today's talk you can go to elwayman02
slash amber dash photo dash gallery and
you can also check out the demo
of that code at ember dash photo
gallery.jayhawk.com
and that's everything i have for you
today i want to thank you all for coming
to my talk
if you'd like to connect with me online
you can find me on twitter
at axel hellfire or on github at
elwaymen02
and if you'd like to check out the
slides from this talk you can go to
jayhawk.com emberconf21
thank you all i hope you enjoyed the
talk and i hope you enjoy the rest of
the conference